Jonathan's a movie reviewer for a weekly newspaper in Chicago. And one day he got a kind of mysterious letter. First off, it was unsigned.
乔纳森是芝加哥一家周报的电影评论员。有一天，他收到了一封有点神秘的信。首先，这封信没有署名。
And it was an anonymous love letter typed with an old fashioned kind of typewriter that's like where the letters are part black and part read because it's like stuck in the ribbon between the two.
这是一封匿名情书，用那种老式打字机打出来的，打字机的字带因为卡在黑红两色之间，所以印出来的字一部分是黑的，一部分是红的。
Right. I remember those.
没错，我记得那种打字机。
And as I recall, there wasn't any return address of any kind.
我记得这封信也没有任何回信地址。
Now you have in your hand a copy of the text of the letter. Could I ask you to read it?
现在你手里有一份这封信的文本，能请你读一下吗？
Yeah, OK.
好的，没问题。
"Dearest, do you know how much in love with you I am? I have fallen in love without taking a step. Did I trip? Did I stumble? Lose my balance? Graze my knee? Graze my heart?
“最亲爱的，你知道我有多爱你吗？我还没迈出一步，就已经坠入爱河。是我绊倒了吗？是我跌倒了吗？失去平衡了吗？擦伤了膝盖？擦伤了心？
You were all wrong for me and I know it, but I can no longer care for my thoughts unless they're thoughts of you."
你对我来说完全不合适，我心知肚明，但除非想到你，否则我无法再关心我的任何思绪。”
And so, what did you think?
那么，你觉得怎么样？
Well, I thought, I do get all kinds of both friendly and extremely sometimes unfriendly letters from readers. And it was not something I brooded over, but I didn't throw the letter away. In a way, I kind of felt a little flattered and curious about who might have written it. And pleased.
嗯，我想，我确实会收到各种各样的读者来信，有些很友好，有时也极其不友好。我并没有对此耿耿于怀，但我也没有把这封信扔掉。在某种程度上，我感到有点受宠若惊，也好奇是谁写的。而且很高兴。
So then, a few weeks later, Jonathan goes to a screening of a new film, a foreign director's first American movie, with Kate Capshaw and Ellen DeGeneres. And he's sitting there in the theater and there on the screen somebody picks up and reads a letter.
几周后，乔纳森去参加一部新片的看片会，这是某位外国导演执导的第一部美国电影，凯特·卡普肖和艾伦·德詹尼丝主演。他坐在影院里，银幕上有人拿起一封信开始朗读。
Dearest, do you know how much in love with you I am? I have fallen in love without taking a step. Did I trip? Did I stumble? Lose my balance? Graze my knee? Graze my heart?
“最亲爱的，你知道我有多爱你吗？我还没迈出一步，就已经坠入爱河。是我绊倒了吗？是我跌倒了吗？失去平衡了吗？擦伤了膝盖？擦伤了心？”
And then it became clear that what I was sent was a promotional device by the studio, DreamWorks, as a cutesy way of sort of screwing around with my head and the heads of other critics in order to promote their movie. I felt like throwing up.
随后很明显，我收到的那封信是梦工厂工作室的一种宣传手段，他们用这种俏皮的方式来戏弄我和其他影评人的头脑，以此来推销他们的电影。我当时恶心得想吐。
In a way, like the indignity of it, you know what I mean? You're having this little fond feeling and then just, oh, it's for a marketing campaign.
从某种程度上讲，那种侮辱感，你明白我的意思吗？你产生了一种甜蜜的感觉，结果发现，哦，这只是营销活动。
And in a way, see what the feeling was about was, oh my God, I've got to meet this person. It's so exciting. There was a little excitement to it. But I also, in other words, was not absolutely sure it was real. I wanted it to be real. And I felt that in a sense that because you're being tricked almost into kind of like you're having your flattery stroked with something like a love letter, I found it particularly insidious.
从某种意义上说，那种感觉是，天哪，我一定要见见这个人。太令人兴奋了。这里面确实有一点兴奋感。但换句话说，我也不敢百分之百确定它是真实的。我希望它是真的。我感到在某种意义上，因为你被诱骗了，就像你的虚荣心被一封情书抚慰了一样，我觉得这种做法特别阴险。
What's interesting about all this is that the movie itself was called The Love Letter. And in the movie, one person after another picks up this anonymous letter and each person thinks that it's meant for them. And then, each person in the movie, starts eyeing people, seeing them in this whole new light as they wonder, is this the person who sent me the letter?
这一切有趣之处在于，电影本身就叫《情书》。在电影里，人们一个接一个地拿起这封匿名信，每个人都以为是写给自己的。然后，电影里的每个人都开始打量周围的人，用全新的眼光看待他们，因为他们想知道：这个人会是寄信给我的人吗？
The point is, I guess, the letter, through its sheer vagueness, can mean what anyone wants it to mean. That is, as long as the meaning involves love and them.
我想重点是，这封信凭借其纯粹的模糊性，可以意指任何他们想表达的意思。也就是说，只要这些含义涉及爱和他们自己就行。
It's specifically designed to do that within the movie, so I guess that it becomes an extension of that, I guess, to do that to the critics. So in that sense, they're trying to prove a point, I guess you could say. But then when I discovered that it was a publicity stunt, it really made me feel idiotic and embarrassed. And you know, it was not a good feeling.
它在电影中就是专门为了达到这个目的而设计的，所以我猜，把这种手段用在影评人身上也成了那部电影的延伸。所以从这个意义上说，他们是在试图证明一个观点。但当我发现这只是一个宣传噱头时，我真的觉得自己像个白痴，感到很尴尬。你知道，那种感觉很不好。
What's amazing is how often this happens when there's no prank involved. How often something is said or done that gets completely misinterpreted because somebody adds their own assumptions to it.
令人惊讶的是，即使没有恶作剧，这种事情也经常发生。有多少话或事因为某人添加了自己的假设而完全被误解了。
Well, today on our radio show, we have three stories like that. In the first, the stakes are frighteningly high. A series of misunderstandings that can ruin someone's life. In the second, an act we're calling Cat Got Your Tongue, David Sedaris discusses gossip. In our third act, Romance Languages, is about unavoidable misunderstandings in two of the things that people care about most: sports and love.
嗯，今天我们的广播节目中有三个这样的故事。第一个故事中，赌注高得令人恐惧。一系列可能毁掉某人一生的误解。第二个故事中，我们在标题为“猫叼走了你的舌头”的片段里，大卫·塞达里斯将探讨流言蜚语。我们的第三个片段，“浪漫语言”，讲述的是人们最关心的两件事——运动和爱情中不可避免的误解。
From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. It's our Not What I Meant show. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是由美国公共广播国际公司分发的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们“并非我本意”的专题节目。请继续收听。
Act one, Froggy Goes A-Courtin'.
第一幕，“青蛙去求爱”。
This is a story of a huge, rolling growing misunderstanding, the kind where one wrong assumption piles up against another and another and another. And when it begins, Shaheen is an ordinary American citizen. By the time it's done, he's come to the attention of the Defense Department at the very highest levels. And possibly also, the President of the United States. It begins with what Shaheen and his girlfriend, Molly, call, the incident.
这是一个关于一个巨大的、滚雪球般不断增长的误解的故事，在这种情况下，一个错误的假设堆叠着另一个，接二连三。故事开始时，沙欣只是一名普通的美国公民。到故事结束时，他已经引起了国防部最高层的注意，甚至可能引起了美国总统的注意。故事始于沙欣和他的女朋友莫莉所说的“那次事件”。
Shaheen is an American, but he was born in Afghanistan. And he worked there for a while in his 20s. And in Tajikistan doing humanitarian aid work. He ran a project setting up emergency housing, for instance, for refugees after the Taliban fell. Gabrielle Galanek talked to Molly and Shaheen about what happened next, when Shaheen returned to the United States.
沙欣是美国人，但他出生在阿富汗。他在20多岁时曾在那里工作过，也在塔吉克斯坦从事人道主义援助工作。例如，塔利班倒台后，他负责了一个为难民建立紧急住房的项目。加布里埃尔·加拉内克采访了莫莉和沙欣，了解了沙欣回到美国后发生了什么。
He came home to Santa Fe in 2002 and tried to figure out what to do next. He began applying to graduate schools, hooked up with his old friends, and he was a little bored in looking for something to do. And without telling anyone, he decided to do a little art project, just for fun. To stencil these figures on the sidewalk of Santa Fe. They looked like skinny alien creatures, sort of like frog men. The stencil was a plastic toy he found in his sister's yard and just laid on the sidewalk and spray painted around.
他于2002年回到圣达菲，试图决定下一步该做什么。他开始申请研究生院，联系老朋友，他觉得有点无聊，想找点事做。于是，他没告诉任何人，决定搞一个小小的艺术项目，纯粹是为了好玩。他要在圣达菲的人行道上用喷漆绘出这些图案。它们看起来像瘦瘦的外星生物，有点像蛙人。那个模板是一个他在妹妹院子里找到的塑料玩具，他把它放在人行道上，然后围着它喷漆。
And the idea was to have these proliferate sort of somewhat magically. It just was going to be this fun, random thing that started sprouting up, the frog men. That's really all it was for me.
当时的想法是让这些图案像魔法一样传播开来。对我来说，这真的只是一个有趣、随性的事情，这些蛙人开始到处出现。仅此而已。
At the time, Molly had just started going out with Shaheen and she'd seen the frog men and had her suspicions.
当时，莫莉刚开始和沙欣约会，她看到了这些蛙人，产生了一些怀疑。
I didn't know that he was doing it. But then I guess once or twice we were walking around the city and one of these frogs was on the sidewalk. And I just started to walk by it. Shaheen goes, hey, what's that? And he did it in this way that I was like, uh-huh, this is the thing. But then I tried to accuse him of it and he just denied it.
我当时不知道是他干的。但后来大概有一两次，我们在城里散步时，人行道上出现了这些青蛙图案。我正准备走过去，沙欣说：“嘿，那是什么？”他说话的样子让我觉得，嗯哼，就是这个家伙。但我试图质问他，他只是否认了。
The night of the incident began as an utterly normal Sunday night.
那次事件发生的夜晚，本来是一个极其平常的周日晚上。
We decided that we've been dating for like two weeks or so, and we're ready to have a party where Shaheen's going to meet some of my friends. And so we decided to have this dinner. And I had heard from other friends that Shaheen is like this great cook and that he makes this great chicken curry. So Shaheen calls me up and he's like, OK, I'm going to bring over the chicken. I want you to have these things and then he's like, do you have a good knife at your house? And I was like, you know, I don't really have a good knife. And he's like, you know what? My stepfather has got really nice knives and I'll just bring one over.
我们决定，我们约会大概两周了，准备开个派对，让沙欣见见我的朋友们。于是我们决定吃顿晚饭。我从其他朋友那里听说沙欣是个很棒的厨师，他做的咖喱鸡特别好吃。所以沙欣给我打电话，说：“好的，我要把鸡肉带过去。我想让你准备这些东西。”然后他问：“你家里有好刀吗？”我说：“你知道，我真的没有好刀。”他说：“你知道吗？我继父有好刀，我带一把过去就行。”
And so at the end of the night-- Shaheen had been staying over at my house occasionally and I just assumed he was going to stay at my house. It was like 12 o'clock at night or something. He's like, I've got to go. You know, I'm going to go. And I was like, you're going to leave now? Now? And he's like, yeah, I've got to go. Yeah, I have to go. Got to go to work early tomorrow morning. And I was like, OK, cool. That's fine. See you later. And I kind of felt a little shafted, like, what's going on?
那天晚上快结束时——沙欣偶尔会在我家里过夜，我以为他会留下来。当时大概是晚上12点多。他说：“我得走了。你知道，我得走。”我说：“你现在就要走？现在？”他说：“是的，我得走。是的，我明天一早还得去上班。”我说：“好的，酷。没关系。回头见。”我当时觉得有点被冷落了，心想，到底怎么了？
What's going on was that Shaheen was feeling euphoric. They had a great night and he decided he was ready to reveal his secret identity to Molly by spray painting some frog men on her block along the route she walks every day. So he puts on his rubber gloves and gets out his spray paint.
真相是，沙欣当时正处于兴奋状态。那天晚上他们过得很愉快，他决定给莫莉一个惊喜，在莫莉每天走的街区喷上一些蛙人图案，以揭示他的秘密身份。于是他戴上橡胶手套，拿出喷漆。
And so I put four or five of these on the ground. And I want to go do one more and I see two cars are speeding up the street. They were just moving. You could hear the motors, they were accelerating. And as I see them, I dropped my materials there and I get up and I just continue walking down the street. And sure enough, as the cars pull up I see it's like a Blazer police car and another squad car.
我在地上喷了四五个这样的图案。我想再喷一个时，看到两辆车在街上飞驰。它们开得很快，你能听到引擎声，它们在加速。我看到它们时，丢下工具，站起来继续沿着街道走。果不其然，车停下时，我发现是一辆警用越野车和另一辆巡逻车。
They've shined the lights on me and I stop and they say, how you doing, sir?
他们用灯照着我，我停下来，他们说：“你好吗，先生？”
And I say, fine.
我说：“很好。”
They say, where you coming from?
他们说：“你从哪里来？”
And I say, oh, my girlfriend's house.
我说：“哦，我女朋友家。”
Where's your car?
“你的车呢？”
I say, my car's down the street.
我说：“我的车在街下面。”
And they say, OK, well, why isn't your car at your girlfriend's house?
他们说：“好吧，那为什么你的车不在你女朋友家？”
And I said, well.
我说：“嗯。”
Where's your girlfriend's house?
“你女朋友家在哪里？”
And I said, uh. I just pointed because I didn't know her address at this point. And so my story's already falling apart. And this whole time I have these rubber gloves on my hands. They asked me, what about the gloves? What about the gloves? They say.
我说：“呃。”我只是指了一下，因为当时我不知道她家的具体地址。所以我的谎话已经露馅了。而且整个过程中我一直戴着橡胶手套。他们问我：“手套是怎么回事？那些手套是怎么回事？”他们说。
And I said, well, my friends and I have been painting at my girlfriend's house. We paint.
我说：“嗯，我和朋友们一直在女朋友家画画。我们画画。”
So they don't like this story and it's already coming apart. And they asked me if they can search the car. I was taking this law course in community college to get into school and the whole idea of having some sort of civil rights was something that I thought I'd want to try and test out. And I said, no, you can't search my car. And that took the whole confrontation up to the next step. The guys cuffed me.
所以他们不喜欢这个故事，谎话已经破了。他们问能不能搜查我的车。我当时在社区学院上法律课，想考研究生，对于拥有某种公民权利，我觉得应该尝试测试一下。我说：“不，你们不能搜查我的车。”那让整件事升级到了下一步。他们给我戴上了手铐。
They said, if you want to play hardball, you want to play tough, we'll play tough with you. And that was it. They held me there for about five minutes, got on their radio, came back and said, you're under arrest. And so I tried to kind of speak with them.
他们说：“如果你想玩硬的，想玩强硬的，我们会跟你来硬的。”就是这样。他们把我扣在那里大约五分钟，对着对讲机说了些什么，回来后说：“你被捕了。”我试图跟他们沟通。
You know, what's the deal? Why am I under arrest here? What's happening? And I finally get out of the officer, well, we got a call from a woman who says you were in her yard and her dogs were barking and that you ran away. And I said, I'm sorry officer, I have no idea what you're talking about. I was in no yard. I heard no dogs barking. I've been in this neighborhood for a little while walking around. There was nothing.
“你知道，这是怎么回事？为什么我被捕了？发生了什么事？”我终于从警官那里问出：“嗯，我们接到一个女人的报警电话，说你在她的院子里，她的狗在叫，你逃跑了。”我说：“对不起，警官，我根本不知道你在说什么。我没有去任何院子。我没听到狗叫。我在这个街区转了一会儿。什么事都没有。”
And he says, oh yeah, so where have you've been?
他说：“哦，是吗？那你刚才去哪儿了？”
And I was faced with this sort of decision of whether I should reveal and sort of start coming clean or not. And I chose the former and I said, well, look, I'm not a prowler. In fact, if you want to know what I'm doing, I've been painting on the sidewalk. And if you want to know where my stuff is, if you see right there on the corner there in front of the car there's a big blue mailbox and you'll find that there is several spray cans and a stencil. And that's what I've been using. If you go around this block you'll find that those are there as well.
我面临着一个选择，是坦白一切还是继续隐瞒。我选择了前者，说：“好吧，听着，我不是潜行者。事实上，如果你想知道我在做什么，我一直在人行道上涂鸦。如果你想知道我的东西在哪，如果你看到路边车前那个蓝色的大邮箱，你会发现那里有几个喷漆罐和一个模板。那就是我一直在用的东西。如果你绕着这个街区走，你会发现那里也有这些图案。”
So I could see this guy shaking his head, just being like, who is this dumb kid in the back of the car.
我看到那个家伙摇着头，心想，车后座这个蠢小子到底是谁。
And he told me, he said, you don't need to say that. That wasn't very smart for you to say.
他告诉我：“你没必要说这些。说这些并不明智。”
After a few hours another guy comes. And he invites me into his car, which is an unmarked Marquis kind of a car. And he puts me in the back and I get introduced to Chris Warner. And he says, special agent-- I believe he was a special agent-- Chris Warner from the FBI. And he says, would you like some heat? You know, turns the heat on. Like some music? And he puts on some soft rock or something. And I'm just like, what is going on here?
几个小时后，又来了一个人。他邀请我坐进他的车，那是一辆无标记的侯爵轿车。他把我放进后座，然后我被介绍给了克里斯·华纳。他说：“特工——我相信他是特工——克里斯·华纳，来自FBI。”他说：“你想暖和点吗？”他把暖气打开了。“想听音乐吗？”他放了一些轻摇滚之类的。我当时心想，这到底是怎么回事？
So I can now get a good look at my car. And what's going on there is both doors-- it's a three door car. Both doors are open. The back is open. And all the stuff is being pulled out of it. And there are four or five policemen there. And all these cars have their lights pointed at the car. The whole neighborhood is lit up from these flashing lights. And I see people taking stuff out, like very surgically and putting them into these Ziploc bags. And then what I see is that they have assembled what I vaguely make out is a collage and they're showing it around to each other.
现在我可以清楚地看到我的车了。那里的情况是，两个车门——那是辆三门车——两个车门都开着。后备箱也开了。所有的东西都被翻了出来。那里有四五个警察。所有的车灯都照向我的车。整个街区都被这些闪烁的警灯照亮了。我看到人们把东西拿出来，非常专业地放进密封袋里。然后我看到他们拼凑出我隐约认出是一个拼贴画的东西，他们互相传阅。
Photos?
照片？
Photos from my car. And then it starts dawning on me that the photos that they're looking at were a set of photos that have just been floating around in the back of my car, a little group of photos that I took when I finished-- when I did the last trip to Afghanistan. It was an office relocation from Tajikistan to Shambe to Kabul. I hired a bunch of these like Russian truck driver in Tajikistan. We loaded all the equipment up from our office. And this is the first time these guys have been in Afghanistan, so it was this exuberant period for us.
我车里的照片。然后我开始意识到，他们看的照片是我车后座里一直放着的一叠照片，那是我上次去阿富汗时拍的一组照片。那是从塔吉克斯坦的杜尚别到喀布尔的办公室搬迁。我在塔吉克斯坦雇了一帮俄罗斯卡车司机。我们把办公室的所有设备都装上车。这是这些人第一次去阿富汗，所以对我们来说是一个充满活力的时期。
And when we got to Kabul, we also went to a place called Chicken Street, which is a street that has woodwork and old artisan stuff and Russian stuff and just guns, old, British guns, Kalashnikovs. And we went into one of these stores with a bunch of guns in it, and my program coordinator wanted to put all this Afghan stuff on and dress like a Mujahideen and take photos. And he did it with a truck driver. And you know, they're totally vacation shots. If you had been in Disneyland you would have done the same thing. And so they got all donned up in this stuff, these sort of hats and these-- what do you call them? Straps of bullets, shoulders, and guns, and they took this series of photos.
当我们到达喀布尔时，我们还去了鸡肉街，那是一条有木雕、旧工艺品、俄罗斯商品和枪支的街道，老式的英国枪、卡拉什尼科夫冲锋枪。我们走进其中一家有很多枪的店，我的项目协调员想戴上这些阿富汗的东西，打扮成圣战者，然后拍照。他和卡车司机一起拍了照片。你知道，那完全是度假照。如果你在迪士尼乐园，你也会做同样的事。他们戴上这些东西，那些帽子，还有……叫什么来着？子弹带，放在肩膀上，还有枪，他们拍了一系列照片。
And then it began to dawn on me that there was a whole new level to this investigation that's all of a sudden-- that I'm seeing this new level now. And it was like, oh, wow. The painting thing began to fade and I began to realize that there's all this other stuff in my car.
然后我开始意识到，这次调查进入了一个全新的层面，我突然看到了这个新层面。当时的感觉是，哦，哇。涂鸦的事情开始淡化，我开始意识到我的车里有这么多其他东西。
I had ministry of foreign affairs. When you're in Tajikistan you have to have special certification to be there from the government and there are these little cards. I had a few of those in my wallet. And my passport, it's an old passport that I've just been using for quite a while. And it's really an incriminating one if you don't know what I was doing, or why, or what kind of business I was in.
我有外交部的证件。当你在塔吉克斯坦时，你必须拥有政府颁发的特殊证明才能留在那里，就是那些小卡片。我的钱包里有几张。还有我的护照，那是一本旧护照，我用了很久了。如果你不知道我在做什么，或者为什么，或者我是做什么生意的，这确实是一本让人怀疑的护照。
And if you thumbed through this passport, I mean, there are visas from Tajikistan, several visas in Turkey. This attachment, there's a visa from Kazakhstan, Kabul International Airport, Republic of Korea, Islamic Republic of Pakistan. They pull out the knife, my chicken knife. It's this big, German chef's knife. And they're pulling this thing out and I see them handing it around to each other. I just see like every check on their book. It's like, you know, check, check, every suspicious thing that could possibly have been there, was.
如果你翻翻这本护照，我是说，里面有塔吉克斯坦的签证，土耳其的几张签证。还有这个附件，有哈萨克斯坦的签证，喀布尔国际机场的，大韩民国的，巴基斯坦伊斯兰共和国的。他们拿出了那把刀，我的切鸡肉的刀。那是一把很大的德国厨师刀。他们把它拿出来，我看着他们在互相传阅。我看到他们简直是在查账本上的每一个勾。就像是，你知道，检查，检查，每一个可能存在的怀疑点都在那儿了。
They take Shaheen to the police precinct and usher him into a special interrogation room. In the room are two other FBI agents.
他们把沙欣带到警察局，领进了一间特别审讯室。房间里还有两名FBI探员。
There's one FBI agent who looks completely disheveled. He has a tie on, but his collar is all stuck up on one end and it's up on the back. And his hair is disheveled and his shirt's coming out. These poor guys, these FBI guys have been called up from Albuquerque, which is an hour away.
有一个FBI探员看起来完全不修边幅。他系着领带，但领子一端翘了起来，背部也翻着。他的头发乱蓬蓬的，衬衫都跑出来了。这些可怜的家伙，这些FBI探员是从一小时外的阿尔伯克基被叫过来的。
Then they sort of the began the questions and about two minutes into it, the door knocks and a gentleman walks in. And everybody stands up. And this guy's dressed very well, short hair. He's got a nice black suit on, black shoes. I mean, good to go. And he introduces himself as Brian of the Secret Service. And they all shake his hand, shake his hand, shake his hand. He looks at me, I'm kind of dumbfounded. He's like, you know, this is the guy who's brought us in here. He finds a seat in the corner of the room behind everybody. He sits down, opens up his little notebook, crosses his legs and says, don't mind me, guys. Go ahead.
然后他们开始问问题，大约两分钟后，门被敲响了，一位绅士走了进来。所有人都站了起来。这个家伙打扮得非常体面，短发。穿着一件漂亮的黑色西装，黑色皮鞋。我的意思是，状态非常好。他自我介绍说是特勤局的布莱恩。他们都和他握手。他看着我，我有点目瞪口呆。他说：“你知道，就是这家伙把我们带到这儿来的。”他在房间角落里找了个位置，坐在所有人后面，打开他的小笔记本，翘起二郎腿说：“别介意我，伙计们。继续。”
And the questions. Then they start asking these questions. And one of the first questions they ask is about Molly. They want to know where she lives. And I don't even really know where she lives.
然后他们开始提问。第一个问题是关于莫莉的。他们想知道她住在哪里。我甚至真的不知道她住在哪里。
You knew where I lived.
你知道我住在哪。
I knew where you lived, but I couldn't give the street address and the number.
我知道你住在哪，但我说不出街道地址和门牌号。
I described to them where she lives and one of the officers, this FBI guy say, I think I got it. I'm going to go down there.
我向他们描述了她住的地方，其中一个警官，那个FBI家伙说：“我想我知道了。我要去那里。”
Suddenly, I wake up and I just-- I wake up to the sound of like someone pounding on my door. Like, pound, pound, pound. And I'm freaking out. I'm really, really nervous and I'm shaking really hard, like something's going on. And this guy yells, FBI. And he put a badge against the window. They basically say, we want to ask you a few questions about tonight. What happened? We know you had a party and we need to know who was here.
突然，我醒了，我被那种敲门声吵醒了。砰，砰，砰。我吓坏了。我真的很紧张，浑身发抖，好像出事了。那个家伙大喊：“FBI！”他把证件贴在窗户上。他们基本上说：“我们要问你几个关于今晚的问题。发生了什么？我们知道你开了派对，我们需要知道谁来过。”
And I said, oh, my friends from work and my boyfriend.
我说：“哦，我单位的朋友和我的男朋友。”
Who is your boyfriend?
“你男朋友是谁？”
And I told them his name.
我告诉了他们他的名字。
What's his last name?
“他姓什么？”
And I said, I don't know. I don't know his last name at this point.
我说：“我不知道。我现在不知道他的姓。”
And they're kind of like, you don't know your boyfriend's last name?
他们就像是：“你不知道你男朋友的姓？”
And I'm like, OK, he's not my boyfriend.
我说：“好吧，他不是我男朋友。”
How much do you know about this guy? What do you know about him?
“你对他了解多少？你知道他什么？”
And they just launch into this series of questions. Has he ever touched your computer?
他们就开始抛出一系列问题。“他碰过你的电脑吗？”
And I'm like, well, I just got a new computer actually and yes. I'm thinking in my head, yes, he's touched my computer. Like he helped me program it. And he helped me put the software on it. And I'm like, yeah, I mean, we use my computer all the time was my answer to the question.
我说：“嗯，我刚换了一台新电脑，是的。”我心里在想，是的，他碰过我的电脑。比如他帮我编程序。他帮我安装软件。我说：“是的，我的意思是，我们一直都在用我的电脑。”这就是我对这个问题的回答。
He's like, has he ever used your computer alone?
他说：“他单独用过你的电脑吗？”
And I was like, no, I don't think so. No?
我说：“没有，我不这么认为。没有吗？”
And then, do you know if he likes flight simulator games? Is he obsessive about planes?
“还有，你知道他喜欢飞行模拟游戏吗？他痴迷于飞机吗？”
And the funny thing is that Shaheen really loves planes and he had told me a little bit about that. And I was like, I really don't know. I just don't know. I'm sorry, I don't know.
有趣的是，沙欣确实非常喜欢飞机，他对我提起过一点。我说：“我真的不知道。我就是不知道。对不起，我不知道。”
They asked me if I had been intimate with him. And I said, are you asking me if I've slept with him or not?
他们问我是否和他亲密过。我说：“你是想问我有没有和他睡过吗？”
They're like, well, in a way, yes.
他们说：“嗯，从某种意义上说是的。”
And I kind of felt like, is the FBI wondering if I'm using protection or something?
我当时觉得，FBI是在怀疑我有没有采取保护措施吗？
And then they start asking the same questions over and over and try to get me to slip up. And also, I've only been dating him for two weeks and I don't really know that much about him. And in the back of my head I'm going, oh my God. Maybe I am dating a terrorist. You don't know. Like I said, I never outright lied, but I skirted the truth 20 times in my conversation with the FBI and I don't know why. I just believed him. That's what's really bizarre about the situation. To some extent, maybe that's dangerous.
然后他们开始一遍又一遍地问同样的问题，想让我露馅。而且，我和他只约会了两周，我对他真的了解不多。我脑子里一直在想，天哪，也许我真的在和一个恐怖分子约会。你不知道。就像我说的，我从没直接撒谎，但在与FBI的谈话中，我绕开了真相20次，我不知道为什么。我只是相信他。这才是这种情况下最奇怪的事情。在某种程度上，这可能很危险。
I could have just said, I don't know this guy. I'm not involved. But I put myself right in there when I made the decision to try to show them who I thought he was. And to do that against sort of the grain of maybe what I should have done. You know, it's really hard to know.
我本可以只说，我不知道这个家伙。我不了解。但我决定试着告诉他们我认为他是谁时，我就把自己牵扯进去了。并且违背了我本应该做的事情。你知道，真的很难知道。
And finally, they left and it's Monday morning and my alarm is ringing as they're walking out the door. I have to go to work and go to school and I don't know what to do. And I keep asking them again and again, where is he? Where have you taken him? They won't give me any information except he's arrested and he's in jail. And I need to calm down, so I get out of the house and I start walking around. And there's all these new frogs, like all around my walk. And that moment I'm like, OK, I know it's him.
最后，他们离开了，已经是周一早上，当他们走出门口时，我的闹钟响了。我得去上班，去学校，我不知道该怎么办。我一遍又一遍地问他们：“他在哪？你们把他带到哪去了？”除了他被捕了、在监狱里之外，他们不给我任何信息。我需要冷静下来，所以我走出家门，开始到处走走。我的散步路线上到处都是新的青蛙图案。那一刻我心想，好的，我知道是他。
Back at the station, Chris from the FBI and Brian from the Secret Service, and the other investigators keep questioning Shaheen. They ask if they can search his house. He asked what would happen if he said no. They tell him they can get a warrant out of DC in 10 minutes. He agrees to the search.
回到警察局，FBI的克里斯和特勤局的布莱恩，以及其他调查人员继续审问沙欣。他们问能不能搜查他的房子。他问如果他拒绝会怎样。他们告诉他，他们可以在10分钟内从华盛顿拿到搜查令。他同意了搜查。
They tell him they want to check out his car one more time before they go.
他们告诉他，在走之前想再检查一遍他的车。
So we're sitting in this big SUV in the impound lot and I'm looking at my car. And Chris abruptly interrupts our conversation and turns to speak with Brian. And there's some murmuring going on. And Chris leans back over to me and in his hand he has this flyer. And Chris says, so what do we have here? And he folds opens this flyer and the flyer is-- the feeling in Santa Fe around Iraq was that we should not have gone to war with Iraq and that America's war with Iraq was something that was being aggressively pushed by a small group of people within the administration. And that one of the central figures in that group was Donald Rumsfeld. Donald Rumsfeld has a house in Taos, New Mexico. And this is the first time I had heard of it.
所以我们坐在扣押场的那辆大SUV里，我看着我的车。克里斯突然打断了我们的谈话，转头跟布莱恩说话。有一些低语声。克里斯又转过身对我说，手里拿着这张传单。克里斯说：“那么，我们在这儿发现了什么？”他展开这张传单，传单上是——当时圣达菲关于伊拉克的氛围是，我们不应该对伊拉克发动战争，美国对伊拉克的战争是政府内部一小撮人积极推动的。而那个小团体中的核心人物之一是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德。唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德在新墨西哥州的陶斯有一所房子。这是我第一次听说这件事。
I actually was just riding my bike downtown and somebody handed me this flyer. I had gotten on my bike and I briefly looked at it and I nowhere to put it, so I just threw it in my backpack. And the flyer ended up in the back of my car.
我当时只是骑自行车进城，有人递给我这张传单。我骑上车，简单地看了一眼，没地方放，就随手扔进了背包。那张传单最后留在了我的车后座。
And so they said, what do we have here? Well, it was a picture of Donald Rumsfeld's head, a real picture of his head. I believe it was in a pile of skulls. And it was something like, crimes against humanity. Don't go to Iraq. You know, stuff like this. And there's going to be a protest staged at his house. When this thing opened up and I looked at it, I swallowed hard and I was like, yes, this is kind of-- this doesn't look good. And I can see how this doesn't look good. But come on, guys. I mean, is it against the law to have a flyer? And they're like, no, it's totally your right.
所以他们说：“我们在这发现了什么？”嗯，那是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德头像的照片，是他头像的真实照片。我相信是在一堆骷髅里。上面写着类似“反人类罪。不要去伊拉克”。你知道，类似这样的东西。还有要在他的房子举行抗议活动。当这件事揭开，我看到它时，我用力咽了口唾沫，心想，是的，这看起来确实……这看起来不太好。我知道这看起来为什么不好。但是，伙计们，拥有传单违法吗？他们说，不，这完全是你的权利。
And they said, well, what do you think about Donald Rumsfeld? Brian said this. What would you do if you met Donald Rumsfeld?
他们说：“那么，你怎么看唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德？”布莱恩问的。“如果你见到唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德，你会做什么？”
And I said, I'd question him.
我说：“我会质问他。”
What kind of questions? Then they started getting into this line of questioning of, would you want to hurt him? Or do you have any violent inclinations towards him?
“什么样的问题？”然后他们开始进入这种审讯方式，“你想伤害他吗？或者你对他有暴力倾向吗？”
And I was like, whoa, guys. Chill out. They're baiting me. I'm beginning to get aggravated in this situation. I'm like, I don't agree with Donald Rumsfeld. I strongly disagree with him.
我心想，哇，伙计们。冷静点。他们在诱导我。我开始在这个情况下变得愤怒。我说：“我不赞同唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德。我强烈反对他。”
And they're saying, well, what do you know? What do you know about Donald Rumsfeld?
他们说：“那么，你知道什么？关于唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德，你知道什么？”
And I'm saying, not much. And then, something does come up.
我说：“没多少。”然后，真的想到了一些事。
I know that his daughter-- they both perk up. I know that his daughter lives in Santa Fe and his granddaughter goes to school here. So I said that and I said-- And both Brian and Chris, they're like, and what else? What else do you know about her? And I was like, well, nothing else guys. And they are just digging what I'm saying. They're like, Donald Rumsfeld, uh huh. His daughter, uh huh, his granddaughter uh huh. OK.
“我知道他的女儿——”他们都竖起了耳朵。“我知道他的女儿住在圣达菲，他的孙女在这里上学。”所以我说了这些，然后我说——布莱恩和克里斯都像是，“还有什么？关于她，你还知道什么？”我心想，伙计们，没别的了。他们还在挖掘我的话。他们像是：唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德，嗯哼。他的女儿，嗯哼，他的孙女，嗯哼。好的。
They head to Shaheen's place, where they confiscate his computer, his CD and DVD collections, and various papers that are lying around. They say they'll be in touch and turn him over to Santa Fe police, who take him straight to jail. He's there about 10 hours before he's finally sprung. Molly's there waiting for him. The FBI still has all Shaheen's stuff and they start going through it, calling him to the office to talk about what they're finding. They're especially curious about emails they've read on his computer, emails about money transfers of thousands of dollars from an account in Dubai.
他们前往沙欣的住处，没收了他的电脑、CD和DVD收藏，以及到处乱放的各种文件。他们说会再联系他，然后把他移交给圣达菲警方，警方直接把他送进了监狱。他在那里待了大约10个小时才被释放。莫莉在外面等他。FBI仍然扣留着沙欣所有的东西，开始搜查，并传唤他去办公室谈论他们的发现。他们对他在电脑上读到的电子邮件特别好奇，那些关于从迪拜账户转账数千美元的电子邮件。
These take him a while to explain. He has to make them understand how aid organizations do their work. How you get cash into a country like Afghanistan, where there are no banks.
这些需要花点时间解释。他必须让他们理解援助组织是如何工作的。如何在阿富汗这种没有银行的国家把现金转进去。
Meanwhile, Molly's getting checked out as well. One day, two investigators show up at her fourth grade classroom and after some questioning, take her out to her car.
与此同时，莫莉也被调查了。有一天，两名调查人员出现在她四年级的教室，在经过一些盘问后，把她带到了她的车上。
There's a bumper sticker on the back of my car that said-- I think it said, "It's not unpatriotic to disagree." And I sort of tried to explain that to them. I said, no, really, what this is saying is that I believe in democracy. I believe in the ideals this country is set up on. They kind of shook their heads and wrote down the exact language of the bumper sticker and there was a little www dot something com. You know, go to this website. They wrote all this information down and he said that they would be checking it out.
我的车后保险杠上贴着一个贴纸，上面写着——我想是“不同意并不代表不爱国”。我试图向他们解释。我说：“不，真的，这句话的意思是我相信民主。我相信这个国家建立的理想。”他们摇了摇头，记下了贴纸上的精确用语，上面还有一个www点什么什么com。你知道，访问这个网站。他们记下了所有这些信息，说他们会去调查。
And then they sort of said, well, I guess that's everything. You can go now.
然后他们说，好吧，我想这就是全部了。你可以走了。
As the weeks passed, Shaheen's story is checking out. And after a while, Chris is calling Shaheen in just to chat.
随着几周过去，沙欣的故事得到了证实。过了一段时间，克里斯开始把沙欣叫过去只是为了聊天。
We got to a certain point where we had developed a relationship, Chris and I, I think. I mean, I would be interested to hear his side of the story. But we were at a point where I felt comfortable talking and so did Chris. And we discussed all sorts of things, like politics and government. And I think that the FBI may have felt that I had information that may have been useful to them in some regard. And they said that outright during one encounter.
我们到了某个阶段，我觉得我和克里斯建立了某种关系。我是说，我很想听听他的故事版本。但我们到了一个我觉得谈话很自在的程度，克里斯也是。我们讨论了各种事情，比如政治和政府。我认为FBI可能觉得我掌握的信息对他们来说在某些方面可能有用。他们在一次会面中直言不讳地说了出来。
I was asked whether or not I would be interested in being paid. I was told that there are some people who had money who may be able to pay me for some information that I may be able to provide. And they asked if I would be interested in doing that. In all frankness, I thought they were just joking. And I couldn't really conceive in what capacity I would work in. But it was clear that they saw something in me that I didn't see in myself.
我被问到是否有兴趣获得报酬。我被告知，有些人有钱，如果能提供一些信息，或许能付钱给我。他们问我是否有兴趣那样做。坦率地说，我以为他们只是在开玩笑。我真的无法想象我能胜任什么工作。但很明显，他们在我的身上看到了我自己没看到的东西。
I was asked, do you want to go to Afghanistan? You know, let's go to Afghanistan together was the way that it was phrased. And I said, are you kidding? And in my manner, sort of as a joke I said, you're going to have to grow a beard if you want to go to Afghanistan. And the officer looked me straight in the face and said, give me a week.
我被问到：“你想去阿富汗吗？”你知道，“我们一起去阿富汗吧”，他们是这么说的。我说：“你们在开玩笑吗？”以我的方式，就像开玩笑一样，我说：“如果你想去阿富汗，你得蓄胡子。”那个警官直视着我的脸说：“给我一周时间。”
I think they thought that I may have known about people, about groups of people, who had intentions. I mean, I think they thought that I could give them a key to al-Qaeda, or somebody involved with it. I mean, they were at war. And this is what they told me, you know, Shaheen, we're at war here. And we need to really use everything at our disposal.
我想他们认为我可能认识一些人，认识一些有某种企图的群体。我是说，我想他们认为我能给他们提供基地组织或者与之相关的人的钥匙。我是说，他们在打仗。他们就是这么告诉我的：“沙欣，我们在打仗。我们需要动用我们所能利用的一切。”
I had the feeling from them of like, you're really at a loss. You don't speak the language. All the agents that I looked at were pretty much home boys. To the point where I walked into Chris's office and I may be wrong on this, but I could have swore that I saw a book about etiquette in the Muslim world. And I don't take myself to be representative of the Muslim world. I'm not religious at all. But I think for people who don't really know how to interact or who are with it, I am. So those are the circumstances around which it seemed like they were looking for more information. That changed as they got to know me better and they realized, you know what? This guy's as dumb as he looks and as ignorant as he looks. Once that was clear to them, then the trajectory of our discussion sort of shifted back into let's get to the bottom of this.
我从他们那里感觉到，你们真的无计可施了。你们不会说这种语言。我看过的所有探员基本上都是没见过世面的当地人。甚至到了我走进克里斯办公室时——我可能记错了，但我发誓我看到了一本关于伊斯兰世界礼仪的书。我不认为自己是伊斯兰世界的代表。我一点都不信教。但我认为对于那些不知道如何互动的人来说，我是个代表。所以这些似乎就是他们寻找更多信息的情况。随着他们对我了解更多，情况有所改变，他们意识到：“你知道吗？这个家伙看起来很蠢，也很无知。”一旦这一点对他们来说很明确，我们讨论的轨迹就回到了“让我们弄清这件事的真相”上。
This period of me going into the FBI office and talking about my life and this sort of relationship that developed lasted for about three and a half months. And the fact that everything that I'm saying, frankly, just totally checks out. There's nothing they can get on me. Except the painting.
我去FBI办公室谈论我的生活以及建立的那种关系的时期，持续了大约三个半月。事实上，我所说的一切，坦率地说，完全经得起验证。他们在我身上找不到任何把柄。除了那个涂鸦。
When we sit down he asks me. Every time I was going in there to sit with him he'd ask me, so what about the painting? Can you tell me a bit more about the painting? We found another one in this neighborhood. So you were all over the city?
当我们坐下来时，他问我。每次我去那里和他坐在一起，他都会问我：“那么，那个涂鸦是怎么回事？能多告诉我一些关于那个涂鸦的事吗？我们在那个街区又发现了一个。所以你走遍了全城？”
I said, well, yeah. I was doing that.
我说：“嗯，是的。我确实那样做了。”
And what were you doing in this neighborhood? And he would say, I am going to tell you something that you really shouldn't know. I think this case has reached Donald Rumsfeld's desk. And I really wouldn't be surprised to hear the President saw it. You need to understand, Shaheen, that this case is really-- they want me to close the book on this, or to close the case I believe is what he said. What he meant was they really want me to find something that's incriminating in your case. And you need to understand that.
“那你在这个街区做什么？”他会说：“我要告诉你一些你真的不该知道的事。我认为这个案件已经到达了唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德的办公桌。如果听说总统看过它，我也不会感到惊讶。你需要明白，沙欣，这个案件真的——他们想让我给这件事盖棺定论，或者说我想应该是结案。”他的意思是他们真的希望他能在我的案件中找到确凿的证据。你需要明白这一点。
Chris tells Shaheen that the higher ups in Washington will probably be convinced to drop the investigation if he takes a lie detector test. In the beginning, he's not sure but he finally agrees and brings Molly along on the day of the polygraph.
克里斯告诉沙欣，如果他通过测谎仪测试，华盛顿的高层可能会被说服放弃调查。起初，他不确定，但最终同意了，并在测谎仪测试当天带上了莫莉。
And I sat in the office with the FBI agent that led the investigation. And then I felt like I couldn't ask him anything. I felt like if he was going to talk to me then he was going to talk to me. And I had a newspaper on my lap and I sort of was pretending to read it, but feeling nervous about what was going on in the other room. And finally, he looks over and he says, so are you guys going anywhere for Christmas? And I said, well, I think the two of us are going to go to Boston where my family is and I don't celebrate Christmas. And he sort of perked up and he looked at me and he said, what do you celebrate then? And I said, well, I celebrate Hanukkah. And this huge smile just erupted on his face. He started chuckling. And I said, is that funny? He said, it's just the perfect ending to this case. Another reason to close this case. Our big terrorist, our big Afghan terrorist would-be Muslim has this nice Jewish girlfriend from Boston.
我坐在负责调查的FBI探员的办公室里。我觉得我不能问他任何事情。我觉得如果他要跟我谈，他自然会谈。我腿上放着一份报纸，我假装在看，但对房间里发生的事情感到紧张。最后，他抬头看着我，说：“你们圣诞节去哪儿吗？”我说：“嗯，我想我们俩会去波士顿，我的家人在那里，而且我不庆祝圣诞节。”他振作起来，看着我说：“那你庆祝什么？”我说：“嗯，我庆祝光明节。”他脸上露出了灿烂的笑容。他开始轻笑。我说：“这好笑吗？”他说：“这对这起案件来说简直是一个完美的结局。这又是结案的一个理由。我们的大恐怖分子，我们那位想成为穆斯林的大阿富汗恐怖分子，竟然有一个来自波士顿的犹太裔女朋友。”
So the polygraph's done and that's sort of the end of that chapter is what I'm thinking. And now I have to defend myself against this in Sante Fe city court.
所以测谎测试结束了，我想那一章就这样结束了。现在我必须在圣达菲市法院为自己辩护。
Remember, he's still got two misdemeanor charges from the first night: prowling and destroying public property with the painting he was doing everywhere, the painting of the frog men. He doesn't have money for a lawyer, so he gets a copy of the police records with the idea that he could go talk to the woman whose dog barked that night, the woman who made the initial phone call to the police. Maybe he could get her to drop the prowling charge. He heads out to find her house.
记住，他那天晚上还面临两项轻罪指控：潜行和破坏公共财产，因为他到处涂鸦，画那些蛙人。他没钱请律师，所以他拿了一份警方的记录，想去和那天晚上狗叫的主人谈谈，就是那个最初报警的人。也许他能让她撤销潜行指控。他出发去寻找她的房子。
And so I'm cruising around the neighborhood with these records in hand. And I'm in the same neighborhood where those marks are. And I see the address here and I end up at this little house at the end of this little dirt road. It's kind of a Spanish style, Colonial style, Adobe house. Kind of a sprawling little home. A sprawling large home, actually.
我拿着这些记录在街区里兜圈子。我在那个有那些图案的同一个街区。我看到了地址，最后来到这条土路尽头的一栋小屋。那是某种西班牙风格，殖民风格的土坯房。是个有点散乱的小屋。事实上，是一个散乱的大房子。
And I go walk into the gate and there's a big dog at the door. It's a large, white dog that is initially kind of aggressive. And I'm thinking, how am I going to get through this? There are two big SUVs in the driveway. And I kind of gesture to the dog. And the dog comes up to me very friendly. And so I pat the dog and I throw the dog a stick. And that's it, we were friends from there. I'm like, all right, great.
我走进大门，门边有一条大狗。那是一条很大的白狗，起初有点攻击性。我在想，我该怎么过去？车道上有两辆大SUV。我向那条狗打了个手势。狗跑过来，非常友好。我拍了拍狗，给它扔了一根棍子。就是这样，我们就成了朋友。我心想，好吧，太棒了。
So I walk into the front yard of this area and I'm looking in through these sliding glass doors. I'm looking into a beautiful kitchen. And nobody is there. And I knock on the glass. To this point I haven't looked at who this person is. And so I finally look down on the record just as I'm glancing through it. And I look on and there is this victim information and I see the address. You know, she's a woman. She's white. She's 145 pounds. She's non-Hispanic. Here's her social security number. She's 5 foot 6, born in 1956.
所以我走进这个区域的前院，通过滑动玻璃门往里看。我看着一个漂亮的厨房。里面没人。我敲了敲玻璃。直到这一刻，我还没看这个人是谁。最后，我在浏览记录时向下看了一眼。我看着上面，那是受害者信息，我看到了地址。你知道，她是个女人。她是白人。她145磅。她不是拉丁裔。这是她的社会保障号码。她5英尺6英寸，出生于1956年。
And I go and knock on the door. And I knock on the door and I look at the name and it says Rumsfeld, Valerie. And I [BLEEP] myself.
我走过去敲门。我敲门时，看着名字，上面写着：拉姆斯菲尔德，瓦莱丽。我吓得差点拉裤子里。
I literally have a little spasm right there. Valerie Rumsfeld. In that moment, it just hits me like a brick. All the pieces begin to come together. I understand why-- [SNAP] the painting. I get it. This painting was to them, like some sort of terrorist scheme. It was targeting the neighborhood for an aerial bombardment or something. Who knows what it was? You know, some private method of communication between terrorists or something. It all comes together. It's the painting.
我当时简直痉挛了一下。瓦莱丽·拉姆斯菲尔德。那一刻，它像砖头一样砸向我。所有的碎片都拼凑起来了。我明白为什么——[啪]那个涂鸦。我明白了。对他们来说，这个涂鸦就像某种恐怖主义阴谋。它是在瞄准街区进行空中轰炸还是什么的。谁知道那是什么？你知道，某种恐怖分子之间的私人通讯方式还是什么的。一切都连起来了。就是那个涂鸦。
And so that realization dawns on me and I look at the dog all of a sudden in a new light and I think, oh my God. This is the dog that Donald Rumsfeld probably takes to Taos with him and plays fetch with. And I get these quivers in my hand. I'm thinking, I just pet the dog that Donald Rumsfeld pets. And this dog jumps up on Donald Rumsfeld's lap late in the night when they're sitting smoking a cigar and watching the game. It's just this eerie, eerie feeling comes over me. And I'm way too close for comfort all of a sudden. I just feel like I've really stepped into a dangerous situation.
那种领悟让我突然以一种新的眼光看着那条狗，心想，天哪。这就是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德可能带去陶斯、和他一起玩捉迷藏的那条狗。我的手开始发抖。我心想，我刚才摸了唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德摸过的狗。这条狗会在深夜他们坐着抽雪茄、看比赛时跳到唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德的膝盖上。一种诡异、极其诡异的感觉涌上心头。我突然靠得太近，很不安全。我只觉得我真的踏入了一个危险的境地。
And I take a step back and I'm looking up on the roof and I see these antennas that are sprouting out from a pile of snow right by the chimney. And all of a sudden I kind of get a second feeling of ooziness, which is I'm probably being watched. And I walk off and get into my car and immediately call Chris.
我退了一步，向上看屋顶，看到烟囱旁边的雪堆里伸出几根天线。突然，我产生了一种恶心的感觉，那就是我可能正在被监视。我走开，上了车，立即给克里斯打电话。
I say, Chris, you're not going to believe this, but I'm here looking at the offense report and I'm looking at the person who lodged that complaint and it says Valerie Rumsfeld.
我说：“克里斯，你不会相信的，但我在这里看着犯罪报告，看着那个提出投诉的人，上面写着瓦莱丽·拉姆斯菲尔德。”
And he's like, now, do you understand why we were so suspicious about you?
他说：“现在，你明白我们为什么对你那么怀疑了吗？”
I'm like, yes, I finally understand. I can't believe this. I can't believe this. And I said, yeah, I'm here right here outside of her driveway. And I'm going to go speak with her.
我说：“是的，我终于明白了。我不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。”我说：“是的，我就在她的车道外面。我要去跟她谈谈。”
And he says, you're what?
他说：“你什么？”
And I said, well, I'm here. I want to go speak with her.
我说：“嗯，我在这儿。我想去跟她谈谈。”
And he says, Shaheen, get out of the driveway now. Take your car, drive immediately. Leave that neighborhood. And he's like, call me when you're done.
他说：“沙欣，马上离开那个车道。开车，立刻走。离开那个街区。”他说：“你忙完再给我打电话。”
And I was like, I don't know what the problem is with this guy. I get in my car, I move out of there, I call him up again.
我心想，不知道这个家伙到底有什么问题。我上车，离开了那里，又给他打了一次电话。
And he's like, what the hell are you doing there, first of all? He says, take my advice. Don't ever, ever go in that neighborhood. Don't speak to Valerie. Don't try and find her. Don't go to her house. Don't mention her name. You need to stay as far away from this person as possible. Your case is bad enough. So he just said, you know, listen, man. I'm sorry this has happened. This for me was one of the worst cases of wrong time, wrong place, doing the wrong thing, all the wrong circumstances, and you got hung for it. Everything fit the profile. Everything. If you had been a bit less forthcoming, anything could have happened. But by just totally, literally bending over, I saved myself.
他说：“首先，你到底在搞什么鬼？”他说：“听我的建议。永远、永远不要去那个街区。不要和瓦莱丽说话。不要试图找到她。不要去她家。不要提她的名字。你需要尽可能离这个人远一点。你的案子已经够糟了。”所以他只是说：“你知道吗，听着，伙计。很抱歉发生了这种事。对我来说，这是最糟糕的时机、错误的地点、做着错误的事情、所有错误的巧合碰在一起的案例之一，你却因此背了黑锅。一切都符合侧写。一切都是。如果你没那么配合，可能会发生任何事情。但通过完全的屈从，我救了自己。”
Shaheen did have to go to court for the prowling charge, which got dropped for lack of evidence, and the spray painting. For that, he got sentenced to 48 hours of community service. He fulfilled it by wrapping Christmas presents at the local Salvation Army.
沙欣确实因为潜行指控上了法庭，该指控因证据不足而被撤销，还有喷漆的事。为此，他被判处48小时社区服务。他通过在当地救世军打包圣诞礼物完成了这项服务。
I've heard that Chris calls this a success story. And I think that in many ways, it can be looked at as a success story. The FBI's role in it was really to clear my name, in a sense.
我听说克里斯把这称为一个成功案例。我认为在许多方面，它确实可以被视为一个成功案例。FBI在其中的作用，某种意义上确实是还了我清白。
But even though the FBI cleared him, that happened after his name was already circulated to other agencies, which still have him on terrorist watch lists. And it's not clear how to get off. He still gets stopped at the airport.
但尽管FBI还了他清白，那是在他的名字已经被传给其他机构之后，这些机构仍然把他列在恐怖分子监视名单上。而且不清楚该如何取消。他依然在机场被拦下。
One time I was coming back from a trip in Brazil and they got us at the immigration check, at the passport area. And they said, we got him, four or five police officers. And they led me off into a special room. And I was at a desk and an officer was there sort of-- he printed something out about my case that he was going to go to give to another officer. And the printout-- it's one of these old sort of dot matrix printers and [PRINTER NOISE] The paper comes up and it said, suspected international terrorist. And then it was just like, holy cow.
有一次我从巴西旅行回来，他们在移民检查站，在护照区抓住了我们。“我们抓到他了”，四五个警察。他们把我带到一个特殊的房间。我坐在桌子旁，一个警官在那儿……他打印了一份关于我案件的文件，准备给另一个警官看。那张打印纸——是那种老式的点阵打印机[打印机噪音]——纸打印出来，上面写着：涉嫌国际恐怖分子。然后我就像，天哪。
And I've been stopped by customs, federal customs agents in Miami as well. That was a long eight-hour ordeal where they had to call up the FBI. So those are the sorts of things that I'm worried about.
我也在迈阿密被联邦海关探员拦下过。那是一场长达八小时的漫长折磨，他们不得不打电话给FBI。所以这些就是我担心的事情。
Shaheen says he's more careful about everything now. He avoids certain topics on the phone or in email. He didn't go with friends to protest at the Republican Convention because he was afraid of getting stopped by the police. He feels like he could get sucked into another misunderstanding and maybe not find his way out. Lots of people don't. Like Molly says, if you're spray painting one minute and thrown on a watch list of international terrorists the next, you tend to stop taking chances.
沙欣说他现在凡事都更小心了。他避免在电话或邮件中谈论某些话题。他没有和朋友去共和党全国代表大会抗议，因为他怕被警察拦下。他觉得他可能会再次陷入误解，可能找不到出路。很多人都没有。就像莫莉说的，如果你前一分钟还在喷漆，后一分钟就被扔进了国际恐怖分子监视名单，你往往就不敢再冒险了。
Gabrielle Galanek recently graduated with her master's from Columbia University in New York.
加布里埃尔·加拉内克最近在纽约哥伦比亚大学获得了硕士学位。
[MUSIC- "FROGGY WENT A'COURTIN" BY MARK WEAKLAND]
[音乐——马克·威克兰德演唱的《青蛙去求爱》]
Coming up, David Sedaris explains why baboons and cats don't get together and chat more often. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯将解释为什么狒狒和猫不常聚在一起聊天。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目将继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Not What I Meant, stories of misunderstandings, and how they happen, and where they can lead that you might not expect. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act two, Cat Got Your Tongue. David Sedaris has this story of misunderstanding in a very common kind of work situation. This is one of a series of fables that he's been writing lately. He was recorded on stage at UCLA's Royce Hall in a recent talk there.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目，“并非我本意”，讲述了关于误解的故事，它们是如何发生的，以及它们可能导致你意想不到的结果。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“猫叼走了你的舌头”。大卫·塞达里斯带来了这个发生在一种非常常见的职业环境中的误解故事。这是他最近一直在写的寓言系列之一。他在最近的一次讲座中，于加州大学洛杉矶分校的罗伊斯音乐厅录制了这个故事。
The cat had a party to attend and went to the baboon to get herself groomed.
猫要参加一个派对，于是去找狒狒帮她梳妆打扮。
What kind of party? The baboon asked. And she massaged the cat's neck in order to relax her, the way she did with all her customers. Will there be food? The baboon asked.
“什么派对？”狒狒问道。为了让猫放松，她给猫按摩脖子，她对所有的顾客都这样做。“会有食物吗？”狒狒问。
Something, the cat sighed. I just don't know what.
“会有一些吧，”猫叹了口气，“我只是不知道是什么。”
Of course, it's hard, the baboon said. Everybody eating different things. You got one who likes leaves and another that can't stand the sight of them. Folks has gotten so picky nowadays I just lay out some peanuts and figure they either eat them or they don't.
“当然，这很困难，”狒狒说，“每个人吃的东西都不一样。有的喜欢叶子，有的看都不能看。现在人们变得太挑剔了，我只是摆点花生，他们爱吃不吃。”
Now, I wouldn't like a peanut, the cat said. Not at all.
“嗯，我不喜欢花生，”猫说，“一点也不。”
Well, I guess you just have drinks then. The trick is knowing when to stop.
“好吧，那我猜你只会喝点饮料了。秘诀是知道什么时候停止。”
That's never been a problem for me, the cat boasted. I drink until I'm full and then I push myself away from the table. Always have.
“对我来说从来没问题，”猫吹嘘道，“我喝饱了就会把自己推离桌子。一直如此。”
Well, you got some sense then, not like some of them around here. The baboon picked a flea from the cat's head and stuck it gingerly between her teeth. Take this wedding I went to last Saturday, I think it was, a couple of marsh rabbits got married. You probably heard about it.
“好吧，那你有理智，不像这里的一些家伙。”狒狒从猫的头上捉住一只跳蚤，小心翼翼地夹在牙齿中间。“就拿上周六我去的那场婚礼来说吧，我想应该是，一对沼泽兔子结婚了。你可能听说了。”
The cat nodded.
猫点了点头。
Now I like a church service, but this was one of those write your own vows sorts of things. Neither of them never picked up a pen in their life, but all of a sudden they're poets, right? Like that's all it takes is being in love.
“我喜欢教堂仪式，但这次是那种‘自己写誓词’的类型。他们两人一辈子从没拿过笔，但突然间他们成了诗人，对吧？就像坠入爱河就能做到一样。”
My husband and I wrote our own vows, the cat said, defensively.
“我和我丈夫写了我们自己的誓词，”猫辩护说。
Sure you did, but you probably had something to say, not like these marsh rabbits carrying on that their love was like a tender sapling or some damn thing. And all the while, they had this squirrel off to the side, plucking at a harp I think it was.
“当然写了，但你可能是有话要说，不像这些沼泽兔子，絮絮叨叨地说他们的爱像一棵娇嫩的树苗什么的。而且全程他们还让一只松鼠在旁边，弹着竖琴，我想应该是。”
I had a harp player at my wedding, the cat said. And it was lovely.
“我婚礼上有位竖琴手，”猫说，“非常动听。”
I bet it was, but you probably hired a professional, someone who could really play. This squirrel, I don't think she'd ever taken a lesson in her life. Just clawed at those strings, almost like she's mad at them.
“我敢打赌是这样，但你可能雇的是专业人士，真正会弹的人。这只松鼠，我觉得她这辈子从没上过课。只是抓着那些琴弦，好像在跟它们置气似的。”
Well, I'm sure she tried her best, the cat said.
“嗯，我相信她尽力了，”猫说。
The baboon nodded and smiled, the way one must in the service industry. She'd planned to tell a story about a drunken marsh rabbit, the brother of the groom at last week's wedding, but there was no point in it now. Not with this client anyway. Whatever she said, the cat disagreed with. And unless she found a patch of common ground, she was sure to lose her tip.
狒狒点了点头，微笑着，这就是服务业的人必须做的。她本打算讲一个关于上周婚礼上喝醉的沼泽兔子的故事，那是新郎的兄弟，但现在没必要了。至少对于这个客户没必要。无论她说什么，猫都不同意。除非她能找到共同点，否则她肯定拿不到小费。
You know, she said cleaning a scab off the cat's neck, I hate dogs. Simply cannot stand them.
“你知道，”她说，清理着猫脖子上的一块痂，“我讨厌狗。简直无法忍受。”
What makes you bring that up? The cat asked.
“你为什么要提这个？”猫问。
Just thinking. Some kind of Spaniel walked in yesterday asking for a shampoo and I sent him packing. I said, I don't care how much money you have, I'm not making conversation with anyone who licks his own ass. And the moment she said it, she realized her mistake.
“只是随口想想。昨天有只什么西班牙猎狗走进来要求洗发，我把他打发走了。我说，不管你有多少钱，我都不跟舔自己屁股的人聊天。”当她说出这句话时，她意识到自己犯了个错误。
Now what's wrong with that? The cat said. It's good to have a clean anus. Why, I lick mine at least five times a day.
“那有什么不对吗？”猫说，“保持肛门清洁很好。我一天至少舔五次。”
And I admire you for it, the baboon said. But you're not a dog.
“我很钦佩你，”狒狒说，“但你不是狗。”
Meaning?
“意思是？”
On a cat it's classy, the baboon said. There's a grace to it. But a dog, you know the way they hunker over, legs going every which way.
“在猫身上，这很优雅，”狒狒说，“有一种优雅感。但狗，你知道他们蹲下来的样子，腿伸得乱七八糟。”
Well, yes, the cat said. I suppose you have a point.
“好吧，是的，”猫说，“我想你说得对。”
Then they slobber and drool all over everything, and what they don't get wet they chew to pieces.
“而且他们流着口水，把所有东西都弄得湿漉漉的，他们弄不湿的东西就嚼成碎片。”
That they do, the cat chuckled. And the baboon relaxed and searched her memory for a slanderous dog story. The collie, the German shepherd, the spaniel she claimed to have turned away, they were all good friends of hers and faithful clients. But what would it hurt to pretend otherwise and draw that fine line between licking ass and simply kissing it?
“确实，”猫轻笑道。狒狒放松下来，在记忆中寻找一个诽谤狗的故事。牧羊犬、德国牧羊犬、她声称拒之门外的西班牙猎狗，他们都是她的好朋友和忠实客户。但假装一下又有什么坏处呢？在舔屁股和仅仅是亲吻它之间划出那条微妙的界线？
David Sedaris is the author of several books, including Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim, and a collection of short stories by other people that he curated called Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules.
大卫·塞达里斯著有多部书，包括《给你的家人穿上灯芯绒和牛仔布》，以及他编辑的一部由他人撰写的短篇小说集《赫拉克勒斯雕像前的孩子们》。
Act three, Romance Languages.
第三幕，“浪漫语言”。
This is a story of misunderstandings as a force for good in the world. Ben was studying abroad in Florence, Italy, and was frustrated because although there were lots of American students around, it was hard for him to meet and talk and get to know Italians.
这是一个关于误解作为一种世界善举力量的故事。本在意大利佛罗伦萨留学，他感到很沮丧，因为虽然有很多美国学生，但他很难认识、交谈并了解意大利人。
Then one day he sees a flyer, an Italian basketball team is looking for an American to coach them. Ben figures, he coached basketball at Jewish summer camp, right? He played lots of basketball, right? He could do that. He's an American. So he answers the ad.
有一天，他看到一张传单，一个意大利篮球队正在寻找一名美国教练。本想，他曾在犹太夏令营当过篮球教练，对吧？他打过很多篮球，对吧？他能做到。他是美国人。于是他回答了广告。
I'd been there, this is probably two and a half months into speaking Italian. So really, just like a rudimentary, functional Italian.
“我已经在那里了，这大概是我说意大利语两个半月的时候。所以真的，只是那种基本的、功能性的意大利语。”
Right.
“没错。”
So I go meet with this guy, Lorenzo, and this guy Luka. And we meet in this cafe and I sit down. It's kind of that weird, it's not quite an interview, it's not quite friends meeting. And I start telling them about my experience coaching basketball in the states. And they just started looking at me with his quizzical look on their face. And I think it's because my Italian is so bad that I'm probably not explaining myself very well. And they basically say, what are you talking about? We're looking for a football coach.
“我去见那个叫洛伦佐的家伙和那个叫卢卡的家伙。我们在一家咖啡馆见面，我坐了下来。这有点怪，既不是面试，也不是朋友聚会。我开始告诉他们我在美国执教篮球的经历。他们开始用一种困惑的眼神看着我。我想这是因为我的意大利语太差了，我可能没解释清楚。他们基本上说：‘你在说什么？我们要找的是橄榄球教练。’”
That is like the moment where I kind of-- it's the kind of like that nexus where optimism becomes delusion. Where I probably should have just said, well, I'd love to help you out guys, but I can't do it. I don't know anything about football. But instead I kind of did a slow nod and said, yeah, I think I could do that. Yeah, football. Yeah, that's great.
“那是那种……怎么说呢，那是乐观变成妄想的交汇点。我本应该只说，‘嗯，我很乐意帮助你们，但我做不到。我对橄榄球一窍不通。’但相反，我只是慢慢点了点头，说：‘是的，我想我能做到。是的，橄榄球。太棒了。’”
So you had played no football.
“所以你根本没打过橄榄球。”
No football. And I should just point out that my mom would not-- there were two things my mom would not let me do when I was a kid, and there was the same reason for both. She would not let me be a Cub Scout and she would not let me play Pop Warner football. And the reason for both was that she called them Hitler Youth.
“没打过橄榄球。我应该指出，我妈妈不会……我小时候，妈妈不让我做两件事，而且理由相同。她不让我做幼童军，也不让我打波普·华纳橄榄球。理由是她称它们为‘希特勒青年团’。”
Wow.
“哇。”
She did it jokingly.
“她是开玩笑说的。”
That is hard line.
“那可是硬性规定。”
She just did not want me to participate in those types of things.
“她只是不想让我参加那种类型的活动。”
She literally like raised the specter of the brown shirts.
“她真的像搬出了棕色衬衫队的幽灵。”
My mom still had enough of that kind of Jewish immigrant thing going on where she just didn't think Jews did things like Cub Scouts, and Boy Scouts, and camped, and all that stuff.
“我妈妈身上还有那种犹太移民的感觉，她只是觉得犹太人不做那种像幼童军、童子军、露营之类的事情。”
So anyway, the guys from the team invite Ben to come to their next practice. And Ben, perhaps sensing the disaster that's about to take place, Ben has the presence of mind to ask his friend, Aaron, to come with him. Aaron had not only played football, but he played football in high school under Mouse Davis, the former college coach who's best known as the architect of something called the run-and-shoot offense.
总之，球队的人邀请本参加下一次训练。本可能预感到了灾难即将发生，他有心思叫上他的朋友亚伦一起去。亚伦不仅打过橄榄球，而且还在高中时在莫斯·戴维斯手下打过球，莫斯·戴维斯是前大学教练，以某种名为“跑射进攻”战术的架构师而闻名。
So together one day they take a long ride out to the industrial outskirts of the city to the football field.
所以有一天，他们一起长途跋涉到了城市的工业郊区，来到了足球场。
And there is the football team, the Florence Renegades they are called. And the ages of the players are probably 19 to 40. I think the oldest guy was 40. And it was definitely like a rag-tag outfit, but they could still kick our ass. So we'd kind of decided the first thing we need to do is to split up the team into offense and defense. He's going to go take the offense and run them through a series of drills, and I'll take the defense.
那里就是橄榄球队，他们叫佛罗伦萨叛逆者队。球员的年龄大概在19岁到40岁之间。我想最年长的人是40岁。这绝对是一支乌合之众，但他们仍然能踢爆我们。所以我们决定第一件要做的事是把球队分成进攻组和防守组。他负责带进攻组，跑一系列演习，我负责带防守组。
It was kind of at this moment where I realized I just don't know exactly what I'm going to do with these people because if you ask me well, what's a football drill? Like I really wouldn't know. I guess like hitting the tackling dummy is a drill. But I don't know what that's called. I guess it's called hitting the tackling dummy.
就在那一刻，我意识到我真的不知道该怎么带这些人，因为如果你问我，“嘿，什么是橄榄球演习？”我真的不知道。我想就像打沙袋练习是种演习。但我不知道那叫什么。我想那叫打击训练器。
And you only know that because you've seen that in the movies?
“而且你只知道那个是因为你在电影里见过？”
I've seen that in The Longest Yard. They hit the dummy quite hard. So I take the defense over to their part of the field and I say, OK, well, why don't you do your warm ups, do some drills, and I'll just kind of observe. And I know that in this situation it's appropriate for me to stand there with my arms folded and watch. So that's what I knew I was going to do.
“我见过《最长的一码》。他们打训练器打得很重。”所以我把防守组带到场地的那一边，说：“好的，你们为什么不热身一下，做些演习，我会在旁边观察。”我知道在这种情况下，双手抱胸站着看是合适的。所以我知道我打算这么做。
So they line up, probably about-- and again, my Italian is really quite limited. They line up and there's about maybe a dozen or 10 people on the defense. They line up facing the defensive captain, and the defensive captain starts screaming at them. Die Jew, die Jew, die Jew. And they all start running in place and diving onto the ground.
他们排成队，大概——同样，我的意大利语确实很有限。他们排成队面对防守队长，防守队长开始对着他们尖叫。“Die Jew, Die Jew, Die Jew。”然后他们都开始原地跑，并潜入地下。
Die Jew?
“Die Jew？”
Die Jew. And I just stood there watching them scream this over and over again, probably like 50 times.
“Die Jew。”我只是站在那里看着他们一遍又一遍地尖叫，大概有50次。
And is there a part of you where like your blood is running a little cold?
“你心里有没有哪怕一点点觉得血液冰凉？”
Well, I don't feel threatened or anything like that. But I definitely feel like, what is going on here? Is this like some thing that I've just like kind of run up against the wall of like this is like what it's like in another country? And you know, I grew up in a town that was 20% Jewish, so maybe I didn't experience this, but this is what the rest of the world is like.
“嗯，我没感觉到威胁什么的。但我肯定在想，‘这到底是怎么回事？这难道是我刚刚撞上的墙，这就是其他国家的情况吗？’你知道，我在一个20%人口是犹太人的城镇长大，所以我可能没经历过这种事，但这可能就是世界其他地方的样子。”
Is there somewhere in your mind the thought that they are messing with you? That they've totally sussed out this situation, they know you don't know what you're doing, and they're just screwing with you now?
“你脑子里有没有想过他们在耍你？他们完全看穿了这种情况，他们知道你根本不知道自己在做什么，现在只是在戏弄你？”
No, I didn't think that for a minute. I thought two things. One, I thought-- I hoped that that is Italian. That is the Italian language. It just happens to have a coincidental kind of feel to it to someone who speaks English, let alone a Jewish American.
“没有，我一分钟都没那么想。我当时想了两件事。第一，我希望那是意大利语。那就是意大利语。它只是恰好让一个说英语的人，更不用说一个犹太裔美国人，有一种巧合的听感。”
And the other thing I thought was maybe there's this language of sports that people use to motivate each other and maybe this is the thing that Italians do to get pumped up and get psyched. I doubted it, but because a lot of times when you see a Japanese t-shirt that has a misquoted American phrase or something like that? So I thought maybe they didn't realize that this is a terrible thing to say. They just think it's kind of cute.
“另一件事我想的是，也许这就是人们用来激励彼此的体育语言，也许这就是意大利人为了提神和兴奋而做的事情。我对此表示怀疑，因为当你看到一件印有误引用美语短语之类的日语T恤时？所以我认为也许他们没意识到这是一句糟糕的话。他们只是觉得这很可爱。”
And so I go back over to Aaron and his Italian is about as good as mine, maybe a little better. And I'm like, hey, man, does die Jew mean something? Because they were just screaming that like you wouldn't believe. And they thought by the way, that we were talking football strategy. And instead, we're just trying to figure out what they were saying. And then we kind of realize like die means you get in Italian. And Jew means down. So what they were really saying was get down, get down, get down. And we kind of stumbled upon figuring that out together. And we're like, oh man, that's good. Listen, I'm glad we figured that out, but I'm not coaching this football team. Sorry.
所以，我回到亚伦那边，他的意大利语和我差不多，也许好一点点。我说：“嘿，伙计，‘Die Jew’是什么意思？”因为他们刚才尖叫得简直让你不敢相信。顺便说一句，他们以为我们在讨论橄榄球战术。而我们实际上是在拼命弄清楚他们在说什么。然后我们意识到，“die”在意大利语里是“下到”，而“jew”在意大利语里是“下去”。所以他们真正说的是：“下去，下去，下去。”我们一起搞明白了这一点。我们说：“哦，天哪，太好了。听着，很高兴我们搞清楚了，但我没在教这个橄榄球队。抱歉。”
So he quit. His friend Aaron took over the team and the great thing about a language barrier is Ben never, ever had to say, I don't know anything about football. He never had to say, I have no business here and I had no business here from the start.
所以他退出了。他的朋友亚伦接管了球队，语言障碍的好处是，本永远、永远不必说：“我对橄榄球一窍不通。”他从未不得不说：“我没资格在这里，从一开始我就没资格在这里。”
The lack of the ability to truly communicate on a one to one basis, really served me very well in this situation. Because you could always write things off to misunderstanding. And in this situation, it worked very well because it kind of allowed everyone to kind of exit the situation with pride and dignity intact.
在那种情况下，无法进行一对一交流的障碍确实对我大有帮助。因为你总是可以把事情归结为误解。在这种情况下，它非常有效，因为它允许每个人都带着骄傲和尊严离开。
God, what a shame we don't have that in our daily lives.
天哪，真遗憾我们在日常生活中没有这种东西。
I know. Well, I got to tell you, I have an Italian girlfriend. She speaks English quite well because she's been here many years now. But especially at the beginning, there were many, many, many, misunderstandings. And during the courting process especially, she was not nearly as interested in me as I was in her. And I made just blunder after blunder with the Italian language trying to be cute and charming.
我知道。嗯，我得告诉你，我有一个意大利女朋友。她英语说得很好，因为她在这里待了很多年了。但特别是在刚开始的时候，有非常、非常、非常多的误解。尤其是在求爱过程中，她对我的兴趣远不及我对她的兴趣。我犯了一个又一个错误，用意大利语试图变得可爱和迷人。
And probably the worst one-- oh man-- was Christmas. It was our first Christmas. And I wanted to get her something really nice, so I got her a spa package type of thing, like a nice day of like massage and a facial and just like a whole kind of day at this spa here in New York.
大概是最糟糕的一个——哦，伙计——是圣诞节。那是我们的第一个圣诞节。我想给她买些特别好的东西，所以我给她弄了一个水疗套餐，就像在纽约的一个水疗中心享受一整天的按摩、面部护理之类的。
And we always had this kind of like cutesy, spar-y kind of dynamic between us where I would say-- what I thought I was saying was, oh, you're so bad. Not like naughty. It's not like that, but it's just like there are words in Italian that don't quite translate exactly over to English. But from what I understood, I was saying, like, oh, you're so bad. It's like saying you're mean, but not saying you're mean.
我们之间总有一种可爱的、吵架般的互动，我会说——我以为我在说的是：“哦，你真坏。”不是那种调情。不是那样的，只是意大利语里有些词不能完全准确地翻译成英语。但我理解的是，我在说：“哦，你真坏。”就像在说你很刻薄，但不是在说你很刻薄。
So I thought on the little card I would write that phrase, which Merry Christmas, Buon Natale. [SPEAKING ITALIAN]. And so what I thought I was writing was Merry Christmas, but you're still bad. As it turns out, however, what I really wrote was Merry Christmas, but you're still ugly.
所以我以为在小卡片上写那句话会很好，圣诞快乐，Buon Natale。[意大利语]。所以我想写的是“圣诞快乐，但你依然很坏”。然而事实证明，我写的是“圣诞快乐，但你依然很丑”。
So I'm giving her this spa package for like a facial and everything like that. And I'm telling her, like listen, you need to do some work, sister.
所以我给她这个水疗套餐，包括面部护理之类的东西。而我在告诉她：“听着，你需要做点修补工作，亲爱的。”
And in the first moment that she opens the card, did she try to pass it off, or did she instantly say to you--
在她打开卡片的第一瞬间，她是试图掩盖过去，还是立刻就对你说了——
Immediately on her face. Immediately. And it was just one of those like, what? What? No.
立刻写在她的脸上了。立刻。那简直就是那种：“什么？什么？不。”
But they resolve it, pretty easily and for exactly the same reason that things resolved with the football team so simply. They just chalked it up to a force beyond their control. The bullying force that is the nouns and verbs and adjectives of somebody else's language, which in a relationship Ben says, can actually lead people to smoother sailing through the misunderstandings that happen between any two people.
但他们很容易就解决了这个问题，原因和橄榄球队的事情如此简单地解决一样。他们只是将其归咎于超出他们控制的力量。即别人语言中的名词、动词和形容词这种霸凌力量，本说，这实际上可以导致人们在任何两个人之间发生的误解中航行得更顺畅。
Whenever there's a miscommunication, you always have to allow for the possibility that that's not really what they meant, it's just you're running up against the limitations of language. It kind of gives you a grace that you have to kind of give someone the benefit of the doubt. And it's actually a really nice thing.
每当出现沟通失误时，你总是要考虑到那并非他们的本意，这只是你遇到了语言的局限性。它给了你一种恩典，你不得不给别人某种疑点利益。这实际上是一件非常好的事情。
Ben Karlin is executive producer at The Daily Show and The Colbert Report and a co-author of the book America: A Citizen's Guide to Democracy in Action, which comes out in paperback later this month.
本·卡林是《乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀》和《科尔伯特报告》的执行制片人，也是《美国：民主行动公民指南》一书的合著者，该书将于本月晚些时候以平装本形式出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with S Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Kevin Clark, Laura Bello, Seth Lind, Sativa January, and Cathy Hoang.
嗯，我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和我制作，还有S·黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯和莎拉·科尼格。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼、凯文·克拉克、劳拉·贝洛、塞思·林德、萨蒂瓦·詹姆斯和凯西·黄提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以免费收听我们的节目，或购买CD。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由美国公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has a message for all the people who have been sitting in their cars in front of their houses waiting till the end of this show.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他给所有那些坐在自家车道上一直等到节目结束的人带个口信。
Get out of the driveway now.
现在离开车道。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，美国公共广播国际公司。